Terminator zones on distant planets
could Harbor life you see Irvine
astronomers say these in-between regions
could be prime sites for liquid water in
a new study University of California
Irvine astronomers describe how
extraterrestrial life has the potential
to exist on distant exoplanets inside a
special area called The Terminator Zone
which is a ring on planets that always
have one side facing its star on one
side that's always in the dark and the
thing is
no they couldn't the thing is I'm not
even going to read the rest of the
article I'm certainly not going to read
the study no the Terminator zones could
not Harbor life because extraterrestrial
aliens aren't real
that hurts they're not real and the
limbs just they love it they're so
fascinated by it it's just it made me
think about how many completely
ridiculous things the libs believe in
and yet they call us the gullible ones
they call us the Fantastical ones